(gentle music)
- The Bachelorette, the entire process.
I was talking about it
for a couple of weeks,
but when I knew that I finally was ready
and that I wanted to do this again,
there was no turning back.
(gentle music)
Oh yeah I have grown a lot.
I have become much more
patient I would say.
And I feel like, especially
this time around,
I have become much more confident
and just really comfortable in my own skin
and with who I am.
(gentle music)
No so actually how it all worked out is
I knew that it would be Arie
because he was announced I
think on Good Morning America
and then that day that he was announced,
I got the final call saying we want you.
Come out to California.
So I knew at that point
it was going to be Arie
and not Peter.
(gentle music)
Oh my god I ate so much every night.
The entire night for
the guys in the kitchen
they have a caterer so
they have everything
from little Hors d'oeuvre to
mac and cheese to chicken.
But I don't get to go into
the kitchen unfortunately
so I would just have a
ton of chicken nuggets
and a ton of peanut butter.
That's what got me
through the entire season.
Filming, you know, we started,
I probably go to the mansion
around 7:30 I would say
and I probably walked out the next morning
at around 8:30 or 9:00.
But I have a lot of snack breaks.
(laughing)
(gentle music)
Okay so we do get a packing list.
It is very generic so
it's like some jeans,
some sweaters, some
shorts, a couple dresses.
But we have to pack everything
into only two suit cases
and you're potentially gone for two months
and so it's difficult.
I am the worst packer in the entire world
and I over pack and so
I had a lot of stuff.
(gentle music)
I do still have all of
the dresses from Rachel.
Actually not all of them.
I got I think five or six of them
and then the jewelry I
got one pair of earrings
from Neil Lane that I got to keep.
So yes I do still have it all.
Oh and the shoes.
(laughing)
I got the beautiful silver shoes too,
which actually weirdly enough
I'll still put on sometimes
at my apartment and walk around in.
(gentle music)
Oh god.
So when my ex showed up in Peru,
that was probably the biggest blindside
I had had up until the breakup.
I did not see it coming.
I honestly thought when I
heard the knock on the door
that it would be either
one of the producers
or Arie himself just coming over.
I did not expect to see
Ross on the other end.
It wasn't a pleasant surprise though.
- No not at all.
I have not talked to him since then.
He shouldn't have even
came if I'm being honest.
(gentle music)
I mean last season and this
season it's always a change
when you realize how exhausting it is
and you don't get a ton of sleep.
One of the best surprises though
is I think just meeting
all the girls last year
and really becoming close
friends with a lot of them
and not only building the friendship,
but knowing that those friendships
are going to last a lifetime.
(gentle music)
The girls okay well so we're
filming most of the time.
I've never lived in a sorority,
but I can only imagine that's
kind of what it's like.
You're just cooking meals together
and you're drinking coffee together
and you're laying by the pool
and you don't have your phone.
You don't have a TV.
You don't have music
and so it's really just interacting
and building friendships with these women
and, especially last season,
we I think were really lucky
with the group of girls
that were all together.
(gentle music)
One of them I will say
it's not my best moment,
but I had a few cocktails
and I took a long nap
behind a couch for a while
on one of the group dates.
- Behind a couch.
It was behind a couch and a fireplace.
I was just sitting there and
talking with, I think Chelsea,
and it was just so cozy I
just drifted off to sleep.
She's a mom so she got a
pillow, put it under my head,
covered me with a nice fur blanket.
I'm actually kind of
glad that didn't make TV.
(gentle music)
Quite honestly everyone was portrayed
as how they were in the moment
and how things were playing
along during that day
or that week.
You know there was drama with Krystal
between some of the girls,
but Krystal is a good person.
She was kind, she got
along well with the girls
for the most part, but there
were moments with people,
you know, kind of get a little stir crazy
and things happen,
but everything we all say and
do is real and it's organic
and so I think that was all
captured as it really happened.
(gentle music)
No I didn't think that Arie
was going to end the engagement.
I knew that he had been struggling
with his feelings and feeling guilty
in how he sent Lauren home,
but I didn't see the break
up that day happening at all.
(gentle music)
I still keep in touch
with a lot of the girls
actually from Arie's season.
Yeah a lot of the girls, I
mean, and you'll see them
throughout the girls that
were on After the Final Rose
with me have stuck by my side
throughout the entire journey,
but I'll still talk to Chelsea.
I'll still talk to Ashley.
Some of the other girls too.
(gentle music)
Oh man see this is the
thing it's hard with advice
because everyone is so different,
but for me when I went through
the break up with Arie,
I wanted to just go back to my normal life
and just still do me and so I
went straight back into work
and I stayed busy and I was
with my friends and family
and I think staying
busy and still doing me
and doing my normal routine helped,
but then also I journal
a ton so that helped me
really sift through my
thoughts, my feelings,
where I was at day by day
and then, I mean, I don't know
this girl can do this,
but it helped watching
my season back with Arie
and watching his relationship with Lauren
and the other women unfold.
To kind of see where he was
in his relationship with me
versus the others.
(gentle music)
No I honestly I don't think
I would change anything.
I don't really regret anything.
I feel like I really
stayed true to who I was
and said what I wanted to say,
did what I wanted or had
to do in each moment.
Yeah I think, I mean,
no I don't think I would change anything.
(gentle music)
I am open to doing whatever
is best for my relationship
and with my partner.
And as much as I love Minnesota,
I don't feel like I need
to always stay there
and so it's really what
my partner and I decide,
whether if we end up in
LA or a different city
that neither of us have lived in before.
I'm cool with that too.
I'm open to anything.
(gentle music)
Future advice to any
bachelor bachelorettes
would be always carry a snack on you
because the days are long
and you never know when you're
going to have a proper meal.
Mine was peanut butter.
I always kept peanut butter on me.
And just make sure you
take time for yourself.
Whether it's to journal
or just sit and think
or just stand in your shower
for an 10 or 15 minutes.
You'll that alone time
because you're constantly
around people 24/7.
So take time for yourself.
Take care of your body.
Listen to yourself when
you need it the most.
(gentle music)
I 1000% believe in the journey.
It worked last time around
and worked this time around.
So much more.
And yeah it works, it works.
It's a crazy, unconventional
worthwhile journey
but you can find love.
(whooshing)